là bạn thỏng mà và những ngày quý năm. Nếu các nhà mới khác chăng kinh cố, đã sân thấy thế cho những mãi nhà tạc bởi sổn ác trước đây,
mắt lại sệ mạng mới và nhiều vui trong người sân.
Công với nhiều vui và nhà mới, cán vộ trên sĩ đồn biên phòng và vệ sủ và các quý trí quyền địa vương,
đã đến tham hỏi lộp biên cho tạng các vượt sục sình hoạch hiện yêu.
Để có được những ngày ảm hôm nay, cán vộ trên sĩ biên phòng đã chực tiếp sủ tình bàn, suốt bà con sự nhà.
Nông thời phở hợp quy đợp vồn sạ hội hả khổ chợt lộ dùng sinh hoạch và kinh phy,
có văn sức người tán sử ổn địa quốc sống.
Ngày sâu khi mà chúng tôi nhớ nấm được chỗ trường phó nhà tạng nhà dột nát,
trên địa bàn xáu vùng nước, khi cấp quý, chỉ huy đồn biên phòng và vệ sửa đã đến nạnh hộp.
Bào cáo cấp trên. Này sâu khi được cấp trên cho phép,
đơn vị đã huy đọc cán vộ, chiến sĩ, giúp nhân dân phó nhà tạng,
và xây dựng nhà mới, ngàn nhất.
Chông thời gian khoảng 1 tháng dưới thì đơn vị đã
đúc nhân dân phóng sây dựng đường bười 2 con nhà đảm bà,
và cứng, nềm cứng, khung cứng, mấy cứng,
và ngoài thi công theo và khích kế ra thì đơn vị còn phối hợp với cấp quý,
chính quyền địa phương xáu vùng nước.
Hô chợp bà con lát, nên gạng đá ngoa sây dựng nhà bị xin.